the rescue of johan vest Howser could
well look something like this this
footage was taken by a Bavarian mountain
rescue organization during a practice
operation but the reason Deane cave is
far deeper and more difficult to
negotiate so much so that some experts
call it the Himalayas of caves the
rescue is unprecedented in its
complexity an irritant a rescue
operation at this depth is difficult and
exhausting nobody up here knows if they
will be going down or how far they'll
get seven international rescue teams
comprising at the total of 30 people
have erected several bivouacs on the
long route back to the surface they're
aiming to reach one makeshift camp each
day but for the rescue to succeed
the injured man has to work with them
he's I'm a divine ish maker for me on
how are we supposed to navigate several
kilometres with such narrow sections
it's simply not possible of course we
will assist him on those tight spots and
he won't be able to climb up on a rope
by himself he'll have to be on a
stretcher a rescue operation like this
looks tough enough in practice but the
reality is bound to be much harder